welcome back to new rock stars the
mandalorian season two is
ho ho over leaving us with big old
questions
as we look ahead to season three or
should we say
um three to four separate series that
the mandaloria just splintered into
merry christmas happy holidays this is
wikileaks our mandalorian after show i'm
eric boss
delighted to spend this christmas day
with tommy bechtold
merry christmas mr voss thank you for
your generous gift of five shillings
my family will eat a goose this
christmas i thought we cut those bonuses
i'll be eating a couple bites of that
goose
but my son tiny tommy he's using those
shillings
for his medicine i'll eat the medicine
too i don't need it don't care what side
effects i get
i just don't like giving you will be
visited by three ghosts
tonight the ghosts of darth vader the
ghost of anakin skywalker
and the vote the ghost of hayden
christensen
uh you know i just realized that um
we're in a christmas carol alternate
darkest timeline
where um you know ebenezer scrooge never
has a come to jesus moment and i realize
that alternate timeline is just the
story of america
yeah so true
so true we we don't need a patrician
society
uh where we look after the needy um they
need to pull themselves up by their
bootstraps the way i did when my dad
gave me a trust fund
to start a business i'm joking i don't
have a trust fund i
i wish oh and another reminder that you
can get new rockstars exclusive merch at
our amazing merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com or
epicheroshop.com those are the only two
actual urls if you're going to
some other weird site with a different
url that's not us that's some scammer
who's trying to
screw you but uh in this case we have
good news and bad news we have sold out
of this specific um
latest obsession custom shirt that we
have this is a way
going back in the vault that's what made
it special however
we have new mandalorian designs we
actually have a new one that's just a
celebration of the mandalorian
everything we loved about this season
it is up on screen right now thank you
john uh so you can get your hands on
that
newrockstarsmerch.com and yes ho ho ho
this is coming out on christmas day
and uh if you are like me every
christmas and you gotta run back out to
the store to get some last minute
shopping we have
a gift card that is available that you
can give as a gift to
a loved one and you can do it right away
you know so that's something that you
could just say you had planned on doing
the whole time hopefully they don't
watch the show and know it's a new thing
we provided
again that is also available for
purchase at newrockstarsmerch.com
and as always purchases of our shirt uh
had the option of putting in a custom
shout out that we're going to read
on screen okay so what do we got here oh
one shout out is from jared it said uh
congrats eric on your engagement
thank you jared much appreciated i feel
congratulated
and then there's one here from daniel
munoz that says
new rockstars needs to fill up its
world's greatest vos mug that
is some michael scott worthy word play
daniel well done
and thanks for getting a shirt uh let's
see thank you rockstars for making 2020
more bearable
ali aaron penelope and declan declan
yes declaration what am i saying
uh and then merry christmas gavin uh
placencia um you mean more to
dad mom eva than you will ever know this
is the way oh
and uh shout out to my amazing girl
nikki merry christmas to all of you at
new rockstars this is the way scott
thank you to everyone
who has been with us these past two
months what a time
and again there are still plenty of
shirts hoodies
masks all kinds of great stuff available
at newrockstarsmerch.com epic hero
shop.com those are the only two urls
they take you to the same place
don't go to any other uh bs shops that
are up there
newark's merch.com epic heroshop.com go
to one of those there's some scammers
out there be very careful
don't don't go to just my personal site
why what's on that personal site
just pictures a lot of pictures oh my
god
this season of the mandalorian was one
of the best seasons of television
uh i have ever seen at least when it
comes to like
nerd content right it was a beautiful
balance of fan service i
never thought it could be so great to be
a star wars fan in the modern era
uh and they gave us so much tommy could
you break down for us
what happened this season yes i'll try
because so much happened but let's touch
on the major
major events lots of good stuff this
year old friends
new friends old monsters new monsters
the monsters that were inside of us the
whole time
ah episode one saw mando team up with
cobb vance and the tuscan raiders
to defeat the krait dragon and gave us
the reveal that boba fett
was alive he's a lie
in episode two mando and the child are
joined by
my new favorite character frog lady as
they battle terrifying spiders on an icy
planet
and then they are led off to trask in
episode three where the frog lady is
reunited with the frog man baby
and they're gonna make some frog babies
as was uh foretold
and mando meets bo katan and koska
reeves and another guy who does not ever
come back so
we don't need to get attached to him
mando helps them steal an imperial
freighter and bogutan tells him
to find ahsoka tano and help him with
his quest to reunite the child
with a jedi episode 4 deprives us of
that moment
uh and reunites mando with grief and
cara dune
as they destroy a base that they learn
is being used as a lab to conduct
experiments on the child's blood those
weird-looking clone things that kind of
look like uh
supreme leader snoke uh a little bit i
guess they kind of just look like cookie
dough to me
uh everything looks like cookie dough to
me
oh boy it's christmas time baby and i'm
a cookie monster nom nom nom nom nom
ah episode five it's tonno time
ahsoka tells mando that baby yoda's real
name is grogu
which i think we as a collective on the
internet have handled well
that could have been uh that could have
been a jar jar moment and we
instead have embraced grogu uh lightly
making fun of it but for the most part
saying what else were they gonna name
them
kyle right doug
mr g this is my this is his real name
is chad so that's grogu and you're just
gonna have to deal with it
it's always been grogu she says she will
not train him but she need
but uh that there is another way he can
go to the planet of tython where there's
an ancient jedi temple
an even more ancient stone that that
grogu can sit on
project out and try and reach another
jedi
although there aren't many left as she
says and our minds start to race who
could it
be episode six finds mando face to face
with boba fett
and a revived fennec shand as they
reluctantly
team up to take out some stormtroopers
before dark troopers emerge and kidnap
the child
episode 7 sees the return of bill burr's
character mayfield
as he and mando discover the coordinates
for gideon's cruiser we also get the
reveal of pedro pascal's face and for an
extended
amount of time and some great bill burr
uh there are bad people on all sides
logic
uh just kidding that leads us to episode
eight mando and co
rescue grogu defeat moff gideon
the dark saber is in flux who has it
bokeh tan says how could you do this to
me you betrayed me by picking up a sword
you didn't know the importance of
gideon is defeated thanks to an assist
from luke freaking skywalker
who then leaves with grogu i
know ah wilhelm scream
so yes luke skywalker is here and he's
going to train
grogoo i've got a bad feeling about this
to quote uh characters in every star
wars movie
in the post-credits scene boba fett
kills bib fortuna
sucks to be you bib and claims jabba's
throne which can only mean one thing
he gonna put on weight because that's
just what happens when you sit on that
throne
uh i would like to get on that throne uh
that's it
that's what happened that's all sorry if
that's not enough for you you're a
freaking psychopath
um yeah uh what a season they gave us so
many things that we wanted so many
things that we
never thought we would see in live
action uh
i i if you had told me last season that
we would actually see
a dh mark hamill luke skywalker kicking
ass
against dark troopers in a kill box i
would have been like
yeah okay someone's been being pretty
ambitious with their
christmas wish list but yeah that's
exactly what we got
merry christmas tommy uh you mentioned
uh there is some foreboding sense of uh
of what's gonna happen next with grogu
and we
we did talk about that a lot last week
in our uh finale recap
this week as we look ahead to season
three of specifically the mandalorian
series i think the big question
is the dark saber who is going to claim
it why
is it such a point of contention um
and i think we we talked about this a
little bit at the end of last episode
why can't bokeh tan just
put her pride behind her and claim it
uh when she was given the dark saber by
sabine wren
she didn't have to fight for it she was
just like okay yes thank you
thank you love it oh this goes great
with my armor
it it tells us that there is still a lot
left to explore in the story of how
bogatan lost that saber to
moff gideon it was an embarrassment it
was a humiliation
she let down all of the mandalorians she
had united at the end of rebels
and i think in order to win them back
she needs to have
actually claimed that dark saber um
it's also possible that the dark saber
is not as powerful of a weapon if it is
just inherited by someone who doesn't
truly
win it you know like um maybe
it when she tried to wield it after you
know that rebels
um when we last saw her in rebels it
like did not
fully work as well for her because she
didn't fight to earn it
and that's why mothgation was able to
defeat her in battle
and now she uh is like crap i need to
win it now and that's why she's like
damn it
like i didn't beat him i asked him to
save it
for me um and tommy i think uh
even though mando from his point of view
he doesn't see a problem with this
he did commit a grave error i think
in that interaction with mama gideon he
said i don't care about the dark saber
just give me the kid
that went against what poketan asked him
to do
um and i think that he kind of went back
on that promise
bogatan's gonna remember that and she's
like if you had just
let me join you you insisted on going
alone
if you had just let me join you this
wouldn't be a problem and now we have
this
coming civil war i think you know the
night owls the watch
are very different mindsets and most of
those watch members the armor
they're still alive somewhere and i
think they're gonna see
mando with that dark saber and be like
don't you dare
give that up right to poketan she
screwed over
all of our people with her bad
leadership if you let her have a second
chance
we're all gonna die so i i think that's
they're gonna be tugged back to their
opposing corners and that's gonna be the
the coming the third
third i think mandalorian civil war
there's been a lot of them
uh that i think that's gonna define
they're gonna try to reclaim this
desolate home world
uh after the empire ravaged it turn it
to glass they said
uh yeah and they're gonna fight over
this dead rock in the future of the
mandalorian race
yeah i uh i it's interesting right like
uh
in our first meeting with uh boca ton in
this
on the mandalorian she kind of not
sneers but like
is a little bit condescending about
mando's insistence on wearing his helmet
but she has her own fanatical beliefs
obviously
and and how to how you can wield the
darksaber
so it's kind of like she made it seem
like that
like like mando was in a cult but she's
in a cult of her own that's like the
dark saber has to be one with this way
i also suspect that they're going to
resolve this with like
or or attempt to resolve this with like
there is another way they'll always be
like another way right
like they have to get married or
something like that and like the sabre
can be passed between
family or like find a lineage or
something
uh yeah it's that old legal rule you
cannot testify with the dark saber
against your spouse right
that doesn't matter it's not actually
true they're like i thought it was
oh come on but but that is like like
obviously like writing has become a
little more
nuanced and we take into consideration
that like women aren't just like
subservient objects as much as
maybe it was in like the 80s and 90s
even so like but that you know that if
this show was made in the 90s they would
have to get married
that would be the solution for it would
be like if they're married she can have
the dark saber
but only then and he gets the tv remote
on saturday nights
you know uh tommy what we are now facing
potentially
is what we kind of wanted the ending of
game of thrones to be
in that final season you have these a
male and a female
both worthy of being king of this people
you have your jon snow your daenerys
targaryen figure right
and uh game of thrones season eight
botched that dynamic and
it's so weird and so rushed and clearly
didn't spend a lot of time
developing that relationship and then
they made r2d2 the king
just rolling in this guy
um they did mention the droid gotra in
the beginning of this season maybe
we're going to explore how droids have
the right to be rulers
um i was one of the dark troopers that
evil jedi killed my brother
um no no no i think uh we're gonna see
this
relationship between um bogatan and
uh dinjarin and a really start them out
as people who were
allies but like show what happens how it
works in the real world
allies can conquer together it's really
hard for those allies to have
all their interests line up perfectly so
they can rule together
it's far more interesting and more
realistic to history to
show how their the camps that they
represent are like
actually we hate those people we don't
want to share a throne with them
um so i want to see some game of thrones
action in a good way in the good
like season two three four of game of
thrones yeah let's show
these people's feuding camps turn them
against each other
uh and let's see some politics some
rivalry
uh because i i think george lucas tried
to show us those political
um machinations and the prequels and it
wasn't that good i'd love to see what
happens when like
you have a team of good writers trying
to
explore the mandalorian politics which
is something that
filoni did a really good job of uh in
the clone wars
um and in rebels is how complicated the
mandalorian people are
and when they pitched a mandalorian
series that's what i kind of assumed we
would be exploring
the complex dynamics of mandalorian
culture how they're divided up in these
different clans they all kind of hate
each other there's lots of civil wars
there's this weird ancient sword that
was made by a mandalorian jedi
and i think we have this good
opportunity to show that conflict
yes absolutely so there are a couple
more questions that tommy and i want to
talk about as we head into season three
but first we want to thank some people
who helped us make this episode starting
with our friends at bespoke post
so this fall bespoke post has a brand
new seasonal box of awesome collections
for guys guaranteed to upgrade your life
i recently got a box with a german steel
knife and carving fork
i looked so cool carving up my
thanksgiving turkey i felt like dwight
schrute
uh and i was so proud of myself they uh
bespoke post has got gear to upgrade
your craft beers and cozy threads for
cold weather bespoke post only sends
guys the best stuff every month
whatever you're into box of awesome has
you covered style and grooming goods bar
wear outdoor gear box of awesome has
collections for every part of your life
they have a snazzy sweater box and
another one with a bunch of interesting
hot sauces to get started
here's what you gotta do take the quiz
at box of awesome.com your answers help
them pick the right box of awesome for
you they release new boxes every month
across different categories it's free to
sign up and you can skip a month or
cancel any time
each box only costs 45 bucks but has
over
70 dollars worth of gear inside of it
get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com and enter the
code mandalorian at checkout that's box
of awesome dot com into the code
mandalorian
for 20 off your first box we also want
to thank our friends at helix sleep
so sleep can be hard enough when you're
staying up way past midnight to watch
the latest mandalorian episode the
second it drops
you don't need to make it harder by
sleeping on a saggy old mattress
helix sleep has a two-minute quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences
to the perfect mattress for you one
built for the way you
sleep they have soft medium firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks
off-screen producer zach recently took
the quiz and got matched with the
helix midnight perfect for a side
sleeper in need of some pressure point
relief
they ship it right to your door for free
no mattress store needed they have a 10
year warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free they even pick it up for you
if you don't love it but you will love
it trust me
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq and
wired magazine just go to helixsleep.com
mandalorian take their two minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep.com
mandalorian and then our friends at
manscaped
thank you for sponsoring this episode
manscape not only helped us bring this
whole season of wikileaks to you
they helped us make so many pubic hair
star wars puns our parents could not be
more proud
you know manscaped as the world's
preeminent source for below the belt
grooming
with their lawnmower 3.0 the ultimate
waterproof and skin safe body hair
trimmer
they're also out there slinging the crop
preserver anti-chafing
ball deodorant and moisturizer pamper
your pouch fellas
get them moisturized you're not some
member of a nikto gang with your lizardy
skin drying up out in a tattooing desert
you're an adult human whose balls have
needs give them what they want
throw in some crop reserve ball toner
spray and slap on a pair of their
anti-chafing performance box debris and
let your family jewels feel like actual
jewels for once
if you didn't get anything nice this
holiday season it happens we get it it's
time to treat yourself with a manscape
perfect package
get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com mandalorian that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
mandalorian may the force be with your
balls
[Laughter]
that always makes me laugh i don't know
why i mean the force may the force be
with your
balls oh that's great all right tommy i
want to know from you as we head into
season three we talked last week about
that the fact that we'll probably
see grosgu come back on the show but do
you think we'll see luke skywalker come
back on the mandalorian
i don't know i mean i think i think
actually our
our our our editing editor
extraordinaire john made a good point
that like the fact that mark hamill was
brought in
to you know play a d aged luke skywalker
kind of means that they're not going to
recast you know they're not the
sebastian stan
fan rumor uh or even just an unknown
actor who kind of looks like mark hamill
like that's not happening and i think
that just the logistics of like
the digital uh the aging process it just
seems too complicated if you're not
gonna recast
it doesn't look good enough to to i
think have the life of a full series or
a full season of tv
i think people will it's just not
sustainable i don't think i mean
i desperately would love a show about
luke skywalker you know trying to
restart a new jedi order
but i think unfortunately at this point
you need to recast luke skywalker for
that and we have to just kind of
in the way that you know multiple people
can play batman or multiple people can
play superman
and we accept that it's a new it's still
superman with
the the backstory of superman and the
relationships that superman and clark
can't have with the people around them
the new luke skywalker will be luke
skywalker and i think that
that's the only way that he should
return in my opinion
yeah i uh i feel the same way at this
point they've already committed to the
pot of
mark hamill being the face of luke
skywalker and
either stop telling his story or get it
right you know
like um i don't want to see a recast to
luke skywalker i don't know if we need
more of his story
that's why i think it's so foreboding to
see grogu go with him at the end of the
season
it's like we look at luke skywalker as
this amazing character i
love seeing him badass slicing through
who those dark troopers
but in terms of his mythology we know
where he ends up
we it's it's kind of a bummer they're
not going to be able to erase those
sequel trilogy films
um whatever you felt about luke's
journey i kind of liked where he ended
up in the last jedi
personally i thought thematically it was
pretty cool um
especially with the idea of letting the
sacred jedi texts and that old tree
burn i thought was an interesting
message but like i
there there might be like some one-off
stories maybe like there's another film
somewhere in there there's a limited run
series of four episodes that
you have mark hamill starr in but uh in
terms of grogu he is now headed to a
character whose
uh destination is known and i think
grogu represents so much promise for the
future i think
his story is still unwritten and i don't
want to see him in a grave on notch too
you know right agreed agreed tommy let's
briefly talk about all the different
shows where we're gonna be seeing star
wars stories coming out of this season
so we have mandalorian season three
uh that's we thought it was gonna come
out sometime in december 2021 though
that spot might now be
the book of boba fett which is this new
spin-off series
i i assume that to be the fact that it's
the book of boba fett
uh i don't think it's a book it's it's a
show
but it implies like it is the gospel of
boba fett it has a beginning a middle
and an end you know it's just telling
out his story
as he like he tries to rid
corruption from tatooine and destroy the
remnants of uh
the nikkto gang of jabba's empire bib
fortuna's cartel
uh and he just like rules we finally
learned how he got out of the sarlacc
uh so yeah that's another one obviously
we know
we have this ahsoka tano spin-off um
that
was clearly the the goal of episode uh
five this season chapter 13 of uh
following thrawn which is such a cool
character and ahsoka versus thrawn
spinoff sounds
awesome the search for ezra bridger will
probably have a live action sabine wren
in there this sounds like a very cool
show and it's just going to be following
thrawn's new
um i think his new fleet his new army
that he is building under morgan
smith and uh hopefully something that is
removed from the empire
i want to see uh an independent fleet
where he's just going he's switching
sides he has multiple alliances
multiple enemies um he's playing all
sides of this war
um yes and then potentially um
a new well we also have bad batch we
have a couple we have a lando series
um we have the acolyte you know but i
we might see a mini series that just
follows grogu and luke and
a prequel series to the force awakens
you know showing the rise of the
of the first order um but i guess my
question to you tommy is
do you think the mandalorian will carry
that burden of connecting the dots to
the sequel trilogy the rise of the first
order
the sith eternal all that stuff
palpatine snoke or do you think one of
these other series is to do it
i i mean i of the things that we
of the three that we know are happening
it certainly
makes the most sense for the mandalorian
boba fett's not going to do that
i don't think ahsoka tano seems to be so
explained singularly focused on thrawn
and that i feel like it has to be the
mandalorian
but i i don't i mean like i i just think
it's
it's tricky to do a prequel series or a
series about
pre-force awakens that it would
introduce ben solo like
obviously i think people would like that
because obviously the ben solo character
is so heavily debated on the internet
and like you know his
people are you know there are there are
crazy fans that are
devastated that he died at the end of uh
last sky
or rise of skywalker and all those
things i just don't know like outside of
it being like a cw
like school series like how interesting
is it gonna be to have like young
young jedi uh young young skywalker
apprentices you know what i mean like
especially when we already know
how it ends up like so much of it what's
interesting about the mandalorians
is is it shows how huge the galaxy is
right like
these things are all happening
concurrently or within decades of each
other but these characters don't know of
each other
until they have chance running so it's
not like i mean at the beginning of
the mandalorian he didn't even think
jedi's were real so
you know or at least existed he thought
it was all myth or legend
so i assume it will be i assume the
mandalorian will always be the flagship
show of these star wars tv shows
so it will the burden will fall on them
to do major connecting
between all of the properties but i just
don't i just don't know i i
i think i think there's so much new star
wars stuff coming out that
i it's hard to really speculate until we
start seeing them actually be released
on what direction they're going to take
but we will try
we will speculate that's all we will do
on new rockstars that's right uh
you bring up an interesting point about
the sequel trilogy
if you were to ask me i don't know a
year or two ago i would have said please
give us the knights of rin
spin-off series like ryzen skywalker
last jedi didn't give us
any answers on what that group was the
knights of ren showed up in the rise of
skywalker but still no answers on what
the hell they were all about
other than they were just kylo ren's
friends as they broke away
right unfortunately i think adam driver
might be too big of a start
they're gonna have to pay him a [ __ ] ton
of money if they were to make a knights
of wren series and
i think a lot of people would be like no
i'm sorry the way they they followed uh
the way they did the character
development on kylo ren and ryze
skywalker i'm just
i can't like i can't i'm not interested
in this character anymore
i don't know tommy pardon me is like
okay you introduced uh
some some hints of how the
uh cloning is being set up for the sith
eternal for the
for snoke if they never bring up cloning
again
i'm kind of okay with that i yeah it's
i'm so uninterested in
uh i mean camino with with the clone
troopers i think is pretty cool
but like to i don't want to see how
snoke gets formed
it's it's like at the bottom of my list
of things i give a [ __ ] about in star
wars
and obviously they're gonna do something
with with grogu's blood
you're probably gonna see more with dr
pershing and moff gideon and what
they're really planning
but i hope i hope i hope this is not the
main mystery of the series
um yeah just because i think there are
bigger cooler fish to fry
there are always bigger fish in star
wars as quick told us
follow those bigger fish please yes but
here is an example of one of those
bigger fish i would like to
explore um not necessarily cloning but
basically
the flaws and the corruption in the new
republic and that
is kind of what i think is the deeper
meaning of season two
this kind of a through line that i think
they
they hinted at from the very beginning
right there was graffiti
on gord koresh's club town that said
alderaan never forget kind of stuff and
alderaan kept
coming up again and again almost every
episode had an alderaan mentioned
and i think the reason it was brought up
so much is
uh it was kind of in contrast with these
imperial characters this attempt to
humanize them or at least allow these
characters to voice their certain points
of view
uh and we talked about with cara dune
how she was you know one of the few
survivors from alderaan
and how that affected the psychology of
both sides of the conflict
for the rebels in the new republic
obviously alderaan is like i never
forget
war crime that they kind of used to
justify their own extreme responses
for the imperials like valentine morak
or that imperial pilot in the season
finale
uh they view the rebels as chaotic
terrorists uh
headaches that just get in the way of
order in the galaxy
but i will say the series is very
careful not to draw an
equal moral equivalence right like when
mgs mayfield tries to do that in chapter
15 by the end of the episode he's like
no no no he shoots valentine's
he recognizes the head the empire is far
more evil he blows up all the ridonium
but instead the new republic i would say
are victims of
learning the wrong lessons from the
galactic civil war
they are so stung over alderaan and
everything else that happened that they
view
its destruction as this ultimate evil
that everyone in the galaxy must
must must see as this objective
evil war crime uh evidence of how the
empire is an absolute evil that everyone
will agree with them on
but the truth is we talk about this a
lot a lot of people in the galaxy
probably didn't really care
like most people think about it most
people in your everyday life
most people in this country around the
world are not driven by political causes
they tune out to that stuff they just
want to get through the day
they don't want to die they don't want
to starve they don't want to get
enslaved
they don't want to be like exploited or
they you know they want to have a
healthy family
uh their own health that's what they're
focused on um but the rebels are
all politics all the time um there is
some division
in within the rebel ranks which i think
is interesting to explore and things
like rebels
um but uh by the end of the galactic
civil war and as the new republic forms
they
are lockstep in agreement on what their
political motivations are
they kind of assume that god is on their
side or at least the force is on their
side because it kind of was on their
side
in a lot of those battles uh without the
force luke probably would not have been
able to blow the death star
um and i think the rebel alliance
assumed that once the empire was
defeated
there would be this galaxy-wide
celebration which
there was we saw that in the closing
montage of return of the jedi
but that the whole galaxy that every the
the four or five planets that we saw
represented every planet in the galaxy
and that it would represent a
permanent vanquishing of the empire's
ideals in the same way that in our own
history we believe the the defeat of the
nazis in world war
ii uh represented a permanent erasure of
fascism from the face of the earth
but as we've learned in history that was
not the case
uh those dark forces fascism they don't
go extinct they just retreat to the
shadows
and they transform they regroup they
rally they gain new followers
they learn how to be more discreet and
they return worse
than ever so i think this season the
mandalorian
exposed that blind spot so like
when that imperial pilot that [ __ ]
was saying oh i see that tear well i had
friends on the death star
and she shoots them in the freaking face
um
kyra dune absolutely morally justified
that guy was a dick he was a war
criminal and whatever you know frenzy
lost on the death star they were just
going to blow up more planets they
needed to go
but cara dune missed the opportunity to
learn
why so many imperial loyalists continue
to serve that
cause and you know i would say maybe
cara dune as
marshall of navarro maybe never needs to
learn that lesson but someone needs to
learn it in the new republic
um ultimately tommy i assume fewer than
will because in the force awakens they
all get blown up by the first order
good point forgot about that so if the
if the mandalorian wants to continue to
explore
how uh politics and how
that kind of crap can blind us to what
normal people need and want whether it's
through the mandalorian civil war
or through the inner conflicts of the
new republic
um and and show the realistic way that
works not the kind of like
the way in the prequels it was kind of
weirdly sterile
um but like the real nasty way politics
can get the way the early seasons the
game of thrones did
this could be a really really cool show
that reflects human nature
in a way star wars has never done before
yeah i agree
that would be uh far more interesting i
think the answers are
are in that or for the future i think of
star wars storytelling i think lies
either in
in doing that in in relating it more to
the human experience
and stopping trying to you know create
like you said a sterile experience or
going into the future of that saga what
what happens
after rey defeats palpatine you know
like what is the world what is the
galaxy like then we're basically
resetting once again
and in there there is opportunity to
create new you know
heroes and villains that that don't have
this predestination that everything else
is kind of bound to in these current
shows you know
where we kind of know where the the
universe is headed
so to me i i love this season of
mandalorian i love both seasons i
thought they were both home runs but uh
i i'm interested i i'm interested and
skeptical as to how they'll they'll land
season three but
excited for it at the same time me too
season three can't come soon enough uh
what a great time to be a star wars fan
it feels like oh yeah the ship
is in good hands uh i'm not um
a lucas hater obviously he's one of my
favorite filmmakers and he's
created all this beautiful stuff and if
you talk to him about his vision for
these things
the guy gets it he's like an
understanding of good space fantasy good
sci-fi
good mythology uh so it's not like when
you take star wars away from him then it
gets good we saw
that wasn't true with the sequel trilogy
necessarily um so the way it was shot
all those sequel trilogy films looked
beautiful obviously jj abrams ryan
johnson
beautiful they know where to put a
camera uh they know how to create a
beautiful image
um but in terms of the mythology the
world building dave filoni
is the guy john fabio is the guy like
put dave filoni in charge of more stuff
on star wars and
they are doing that they get that and
that's why everything is so great right
now
but that is a wrap on wookie leaks for
what a season uh personally tommy i
never thought i would be fluent in
orebesh but uh here we are
um it's been such a blast nerding out
with you buddy i look forward to doing
it a lot more in 2021
as movies and tv come back from the dead
yes eric
you know dank ferric i never thought i
would be so attached to these uh
these cute little uh star wars
colloquialisms but then again you can't
hit the backside of a glove nab if
you're not looking out for your trigger
knob
okay so just remember that
am i wrong or did kara dune have like
six of those in the finale i know it's
too late to bring that up now
she thinks she really did which we we
know she
just completely bullshitted one of them
and everyone's just like yeah that's an
alderaan thing
that's the slime lack calling the gliss
lord blanken
[Laughter]
oh boy um this sounds it's becoming a
lusty horde
improv show it is yes oh my god you're
so right
all right sorry anyway eric i had a
great time doing a show with you
as always yeah me too buddy follow me
everybody at eavos follow tommy at tommy
bechdel on social media be sure to
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube
follow new rockstars on social media um
stay subscribed to the wikileaks podcast
feed wherever you get your podcast
because there's more star wars shows
coming out
we'll use that feed to break down
whatever new star wars series that we're
gonna do after shows four so
stick around there's more great stuff
coming um
merry christmas happy holidays everyone
have a safe
and happy holiday and a new year um
we love all of you we don't want anyone
to get sick it's a difficult time right
now but
it's a great time to stay indoors and
watch some wonderful star wars content
uh and we're gonna leave you with the
most christmasy grogu moment of the
season
how about you come over here give me a
hand make yourself useful
[Music]
you